hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 1 video I
think you know biggest surprise was
mostly things that we did not see but it
was a vast departure from the books so
I'll try to explain as we go along in my
in my top 10 moments and new round of
the giveaway starts now I'm giving away
a signed copy of a feast for crows and a
dance with dragons all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll have some
more details on that at the end of the
video but careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet so here we
go starting with top 10 WTF moments
number 10
Cersei flashback this is Maggie the frog
right out of the book they did change a
few minor things but it's pretty
honorable to what happened in the book
Cersei learns about Robert's bastards
although she doesn't know it at the time
20 seems like a high number they killed
a lot in King's Landing like Joffrey
sent the guards around to kill them all
except for Gendry who we know still
alive and supposedly there is a bastard
in the Vale maybe more than one
remember he lived there during some of
his younger teenage years with knit so
he probably has a few bastards running
around somewhere in the Eyrie
I love how young Cersei is just as much
a [ __ ] as old Cersei is like some
things just do not change when Maggie
says gold will be their crowns gold will
be their shrouds she's talking about
burial shrouds - meaning they'll
eventually die some sooner than others
you could take this as a warning that
Marcella and Tommen are gonna die but
really it's so vague that you can
interpret it a lot of different ways
it's also kind of a sidestep into a
different kind of magic than we've seen
on the show we've seen blood magic with
Daenerys hatching the Dragons in season
one we seen Mela Sandra's magic from the
red god we've seen white Walker magic
which is slightly different and we've
seen the magic of the three-eyed raven
all very distinct types of magic I'm
interested to see if the show tries to
tie some commonalities between them by
the finale by like the series finale in
all likelihood though Georgia Martin's
probably gonna leave a lot of this like
figuring stuff out to the reader but on
to number 9 Tyrion makes it to Pentos as
expected he and Varys end up at
Illyrio's old house we don't see Illyrio
I guess the actor isn't on the show this
year the various kind of explains the
Blackfyre grift storyline a little bit
he met Illyrio through a mutual friend
that is part of a group that wants to
see a Targaryen restoration because it
seems like the show might be cutting out
a lot of the young grift storyline the
Targaryen restoration group could be
some other big organization or
would be the golden company the golden
company is just one of the bigger
mercenary groups that was founded by
blackfyres
just add a bookmark to Targaryen
restoration young Griff storyline from
the books we can we can see how those
things match up because they might give
bits and pieces to other characters
there was that teaser that Nikolaj
coster-waldau did with the the duck at
the beginning of the season or before
the season started as of this episode I
haven't seen evidence of a Blackfyre
pretender like a young Griff character
but that doesn't mean that he's not
somewhere in the season outside Tyrion
taking the drink of wine throwing up
then drinking more probably one of the
funniest moments in the episode just a
total Boonton rally on to number 8 meet
the sons of the harpy I just did a bonus
video explaining you know kind of in
depth where the group comes from where
they originate from what the harpy name
is all about so I'll add a link for that
in the description but generally this is
the group being used by the antagonistic
slave masters that want to kick Danny
out so they can start slaving again
there's this really TV style device
whereby they use different costumes to
help you identify who is who so bright
colors here equal sons of the harpy
people everyone else is either a freed
slave or a second son they all have
their distinct clothing styles whenever
there's like a big battle and you get a
little confused just like bright colors
versus unsullied I tried to figure out
what the tune the [ __ ] was humming to
him it might have just been something
from the Summer Isles like wherever he
was from like something that his mother
may have hummed to him before he was
sold to slavers and became a nun solid
warrior but it was kind of funny that he
was like okay put your pants back on
this is fine we don't we don't need to
do it this way this also this new person
on Daenerys is council is one of the
slaves that we met in season 4 someone
from the inside of Marine who advocated
supporting Daenerys his cause from the
inside so it looks like she's elevated
him to her version of the small Council
on to number 7 [ __ ] is brewing up at the
wall in the wake of the battle with the
wildlings so it hasn't been that long
and they're still trying to figure out
what to do with the wildlings Alliser
thorne and Janos Slynt if they had their
way we probably just turn them loose to
the mercy of the haunted forest in the
White Walkers and whatever else would
want to eat them out there Don isn't in
love with the wildlings but he doesn't
want to turn them away if he doesn't
have to he just wants to avoid more
bloodshed
the fact that he's spending so much time
with Olly here training Olly makes me a
little bit worried it's like the people
with the brightest faces usually have
the biggest targets on their backs
on to number six Stannis wants Jon Snow
to get the wildlings to fight for him
this is also right out of the books
Stannis wants to make a deal with the
wildlings they're big force they're
great fighters he's going to need them
if he's going to take King's Landing
taking back Winterfell is like a whole
other thing yes he does have enough
people to take back Winterfell
but because winter is coming they might
get buried in snow so it could cause a
huge problem so the more people they
have the better and as of right now
they're running short and supply so it's
like there's almost no food up at the
wall so things can't stay the way
they've been the wildlings either have
to take off or they have to go with
Stannis the kids just sit around the big
holdup is that mance won't bend the knee
that's what Jon has to do he has to get
him to bend the knee onto number 5
Littlefinger and Sansa stashed the sweet
Robin in the countryside of the Eyrie
the big takeaway here is that they're
just stashing him away so they can't
cause any problems right now he's the
lord of the Vale so he is very dangerous
just for the sheer fact that he has so
much power as we see in this scene
though he is a complete and utter fool
so no one's too worried about him as
long as he's off sitting in a corner
somewhere if you look really hard you
can almost see Santa's eyes rolling into
the back of her head as this all happens
on to number 4 intro to the sparrows so
in King's Landing Cersei starts to Eagle
Eye Margaery we get like a teaser for
the war that they're going to start
between each other all sudden Lancel
comes out of left field like he's been
brainwashed and says I've been washed in
the light of the seven this is setting
up a really big book plot so if you know
where this goes just please use spoiler
tags because it's very important for
this season what you need to remember
though is that Cersei is making her own
plants deal with Marjorie Marjorie with
Cersei so they have this thing going on
and then there's the church in the
background so those three forces are
going to be affecting each other in
really really big ways
Lancel is just like our introduction to
the sparrows until we meet the high
Sparrow on so number three his dart
compels Daenerys to reopen the fighting
pits of Meereen remember his door is
like the representative of all the
slaving families he's a member of one of
the slaving families even though he
seems fairly harmless I think that he's
going to turn out to be the harpy the
one controlling the sons of the harpy
but they do call back to the wise
masters of yunkai so they've been back
like the wise masters took power
whenever Daenerys left they took back
power so now she's trying to set up more
of a like a republic situation where you
have a
group of people ruling the city we'll
see if that lasts I'm gonna go ahead and
bet on no I did like Dario's backstory
like he narrates his backstory my mother
sold me into slavery but hey you know I
turned into a great fighter and helped
me survive it makes me a little wary of
Daario but but so far he hasn't given me
a reason to think that he's going to
betray Daenerys in a big way not as much
as I think that his door will on to
number two Varys explains to Tyrion why
he wants Daenerys on the Iron Throne
it's always interesting to find out you
know what the characters like the
Westerosi characters think of Daenerys
we as the audience are privileged and
that we get to spend a lot of time with
Daenerys but Tyrion only knows of
Daenerys what he's been told and as he
said he was drunk during most of those
small council meetings so he barely
remembers someone stronger than Tommen
but softer than Stannis
although Stannis does seem like he has a
heart like whenever he has scenes with
his daughter Shireen he seems fairly
loving loving in a like an icy-cold
Stannis kind of way I think what Varys
is implying is is that he wants Tyrion
to go beyond two nurses small Council
more than anything he's a gifted
politician so he can help Daenerys with
her people problem Daenerys can raise
soldiers that's not her problem it's
dealing with citizens that's her problem
and finally my number one WTF moment
Mance Rayder burned at the stake this is
also right out of the books he gets
burned at the stake but it seems like
they departed from the books I don't
want to give away too many spoilers
because it's at the end of book 5 and
most people haven't read that Melisandre
uses a little bit of her glamour magic
and there's a bit of a twist in the plot
I'm assuming that they just cut that out
so unless we see otherwise in a future
episode just assume that mance is dead
the book stuff spills over into
Rattleshirt and it seems like
Rattleshirt was in the trailer so
whenever we see him in in like a future
episode I'll explain that a little bit
more but the big takeaway is that they
kill mance so they're gonna try and
treat with the Lord of bones
he's like the new leader of the
wildlings so hopefully he and Jon can
come to an arrangement here's my big
question for you guys though you know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and you know once Tyrion
eventually makes it to Daenerys what do
you think that he's going to be helping
her with specifically like what is she
going to ask him to do I think it would
really just be the same stuff he did
when he was handed the King in season 2
mostly like tedious administrative stuff
managing managers
so that everything in the city just ran
smoothly he's also a really good battle
planner too I'd be interested to see you
know who is better at making war Tirion
or Dario Dario is a better fighter and
he does lead the second son's but that
doesn't make him a genius war master the
army that Daenerys has is vastly greater
in size than the second sons Dario is
more like a spec ops guy like when you
need to infiltrate somewhere or some
covert op that's the person you send in
some of my other favorite moments though
we're like the creepy looks that
characters were giving each other like I
mean you know there was a nice creepy
moment with Jaime and Cersei above
Tywin's body not quite the same as the
last time they were standing over a dead
body
I didn't say a lot about Tywin's funeral
there is a small change from the books
he farts a lot like it's really stinky
and it ends up being this really funny
thing because it's such a powerful
person and everyone hates him pot and
Brienne were a lot of fun too mostly I'm
just happy that she's not dead
Melisandre looking at Jon Snow too
though oh man she was looking at him
like he was like a piece of cake or
something like she was just gonna eat
him in Daenerys visiting Viserion and
regal I'm just waiting for them to go
apeshit just a reminder my Q&A for this
is going to post tomorrow we'll announce
the winners of my book giveaway the
signed books my next bonus video will
post next Sundays if you have any
requests for that just leave them in the
comments I might do like house of black
and white or something like that if
anyone wants to help me out with
subtitles you can actually submit
fansubs for any of my videos so if you
just want to do like Game of Thrones
videos that'd be amazing that'd be like
a huge help to me if someone does it on
a regular basis there also might be like
an extra gift card in there for them too
so in case you guys haven't seen it yet
you can click here to learn more about
the history of the the sons of the harpy
in Mereen and you can click here for the
Q&A video I'll update that annotation as
soon as I post that video tomorrow thank
you so much for watching this is going
to be such an awesome season everybody
let's high-five
I'll see you tomorrow
you